why does everybody know who Grant
Cardone is for the most part why don't
they know Evan as well and a lot of that
is because you've been building in the
dark we're gonna be the first to make it
happen how do you feel about that I like
it I'm scared I'm nervous I'm anxious
and I like it
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine now I've decided to blow
up I've decided to become a household
name and take my channel to ten million
plus YouTube subscribers I decided to
play a bigger game and take you on my
climb with me and I'm scared and I'm
nervous and you're gonna see the ups and
downs in the entire journey first off I
want to thank everybody for all your
support on the last episode it's
overwhelming it's amazing it's great to
know that there's so many people out
there supporting me on my path and my
journey ain't I'm I'm just even more
pumped about this whole series and
hopefully it encourages and inspires you
to play a bigger game in what you're
doing as well so in this episode I sit
down with my agent Steve we talked about
making bolder beds bigger plays and the
game plan to go after the 22 crew the 22
people that I want to get on this
channel that would be game breaking for
entrepreneurs and for my channel
together I hope you enjoyed the episode
all right ladies and gentlemen this is
mr. Steve
Karlis I've known Steve for how long
Steve gotta be six seven years six seven
years he's been the man behind the plane
for a lot of the content that I put up a
lot of the strategies he's camera-shy so
this is amazing that we get to bring him
on camera for this I'm not camera shy in
the opposite of camera shy I'm just that
camera by voluminous he's that camera
voluminous alright we'll go with that
Steve tell tell everybody what it is
that you do thank Norman and I are
partners in to market media we help
experts and companies build their brands
develop content that supports that
brands and then help them monetize and
sell it
Evans being generous you know I think
Evans done almost everything on his own
we haven't been as active with evidence
I would have liked but he's done it
without us but we have built some
amazing brands we built you know Grant
Cardone and Bill Robbins from scratch we
trained both of them from the initial
stages and helped build
they're platforms and now we do the same
thing for companies companies looking to
expand on their their their their
customer base and how do you do it today
ever knows it better than anybody is you
got to talk to your customers and engage
them create content for them and help
them and then they want more so that's
what we help folks do so now it's it's
Evan Carmichael's turn to become the
firebrand you know you and I have always
talked about this right it's you've
built an amazing foundation you're one
of the biggest folks in the small
business world people look to you and a
lot of people know who you are in that
world but I've said to you frequently in
the past and as we started to get
re-engaged again why does everybody know
who Grant Cardone is for the most part
it's not when I say everyone obviously I
don't know if the regular house mom
those who know this although a bunch of
are do why don't they know Evan as well
and a lot of that is because you've been
building in the dark and you talk about
me being camera shy you're not camera
shy but you're largess shy you should be
out there doing your own growth con you
should be out there with the biggest
names the biggest personalities because
you're more subscribers than anybody of
a million seven now I guess it is yeah
it doesn't you know and for me somebody
who's so good on camera and you care as
much as anybody I've ever met you really
truly do want to help people the best
way to do that is get more attention
I'll never forget grant tells the story
now but many years ago I said to him you
know what do you want to do and he said
I want to help more people I said that's
the wrong answer
he's got huh I said I want you to say I
want to be famous he's like that's the
dumbest thing I ever heard I said no the
more things you are are the more people
will know you and then the more people
you can help so if you actually
legitimately want to help people the
best way to get there is by becoming
famous and that's a fact whether you
like it or not and that's what we're
talking about right now we're talking
about how do we make even more famous by
giving him big big missions that he may
not actually hit and Evan might actually
fail and that's what our agenda is
together how do you feel about that I
like it I'm scared I'm nervous I'm
anxious and I like it so let's go so
what's next so what do we talk about we
talk about what are the pillars of those
big things you can pull off
so step one was you had this 23 city
tour which is amazing right that
everybody would love to come see you but
what did we make you do well you meet me
start charging for it which you hate
which I hated
yeah and now I've accepted and we're
doing so what do you think George you
let's talk about that so why do you hate
charging people to come see you um good
question why do I hate charging people
I'm I'm afraid of not giving them value
I'm afraid of disappointing people and
and I know that not everybody can get in
even though it's not an expensive ticket
yes but what do we know also we know a
few things one is you will always over
deliver it that's your nature correct
that's a make-believe concern correct
sure for what it was now now that we
started charging it now I had to bring
more value now I had to get prizes now I
had to like really put effort into what
my three hours talk is gonna be do you
work it uh put effort in before uh well
no not really
well listen a coffee shop meet up
there's there's there's no planning on
my part requires show up answer
questions give value like it's gonna be
amazing
but it's a lot of effort of 23 cities to
do a random casual coffee shop beat up
that sounds crazy to me yeah yeah I mean
we did the tour the starting point of
the tour was not blow up Evan and get
famous and it's great that it's like
evolved into that but it was to take my
wife to every city with a million-plus
people and then I love meeting fans I
said hey why don't I meet up fans along
the way and use coffee shop meetups and
so from a business perspective was
really small undocumented put on my
youtube channel there yeah and when I
met you in New York and said okay hey
you got a charge for it and play a
bigger game like okay wow that that's
scary but let's do it yeah and now that
we're charging it's not with the ticket
I think it's 45 bucks or something
that's not super pricey you know one
thing we've learned in our experience as
to market is you know we used to
sometimes just work on a commission for
someone and we still do that to some
extent but it's you gotta be super
famous already have stuff monetized
because people don't pay you it's too
easy for them to leave you they don't
take it seriously when somebody pays you
something
take it down here it's $5.00 or $500 you
have an obligation to claim value on
their investment I think that's an
important step there yeah and so now
it's bringing a lot more value to the
workshops you know I was up last night
thinking about how to make even better
how do I make it even better how to
bring you more value how to make this
three hours count for people yes
the idea of disappointing somebody
destroys me and so I won't like it
the strength is it means that I over
deliver the weakness is still the fear
that I'm gonna let somebody down yes
what you want you never do
um well you know what I know be it'll be
some people I will and I have to be okay
with that like I went to the Tony
Robbins thing and there's a person who
passed out sleeping next to me while
weird like doing the jumping and all
that stuff and then his wife her
girlfriend was like trying to get him
back into it and he ended up leaving and
then she ended up leaving like half an
hour later looks like Tony Robbins like
the best of the best
did who everybody who paid a thousand
bucks plus to get into his event well
that's an important point though right
you uh you don't like haters haters pure
haters I don't I don't care about I
don't like people feeling like they
misunderstand in tension like I'm trying
to help them and they see someone else
but you know the more you the bigger and
bigger you get continue to grow yeah
where you puts a charge you're gonna
have more people that are not happy
that's just like I think part of the
problem in terms of you really going for
the for the for the biggest thing is
your concern about that yeah
which we're now force feeding to you
yeah so first thing is I love the 23
city tour yeah I think we can build our
own bigger single tour two or conference
after that let's see how that goes okay
know the point here is let's do let's do
big things and the tour is a big thing
that can evolve into something bigger
the second big thing we're talking about
is how do we get you to ten million
subscribers right what do you think is
gonna be the key to get there I think
it'd be a mix of what we're talking but
also the other series and other people
like psychologists and Hank and those
guys to make me better I think though
that the idea we had of getting the 22
crew the 22 people who
haven't really been as local on YouTube
or entrepreneurship a couple of them
have but people who would either make my
channel help blow up or just for the
entire community industry to get their
thoughts on entrepreneurship there's
some of the like 22 of the hardest
people in the world to get access to
almost so what's our game plan to kind
of get them on board and allowing people
that gonna watch my journey to bring
them in look you people you're met today
have you shared that with everybody in
terms of who that list is to my audience
just last week in the intro video
basically announcing what this is all
about yeah we could definitely play
bigger you know I could I could put it
out in the newsletter it could be it'll
be an ongoing part of this series for
people who are watching obviously part
of what we're talking about in terms of
getting to 10 million is going for
bigger things and getting 22 of the
biggest names in the world yeah come on
your show and to be a part of what
you're doing to and to impact people is
a huge thing so that's also a challenge
for you too right it's it's it is scary
to say publicly I'm going to be cleaning
after these 22 folks and I think that's
part of what will drive you because I I
know you so well in terms of when
there's a challenge in front of you you
will do everything you can to get it so
I think that's a good thing how do we do
it at a number one one of the things
that will be couple is having us help
you do that so it's you have a team
that's helping you you're not solo I
think between us we have six degrees of
separation to a lot of those people I
think it's pretty easy to get people
excited when they see the type of
numbers that you already have on your
YouTube subscription list yeah and I
think a lot of that is styled so it's a
combination of the style in which we
approach the relationships and the six
degrees of separation is really
important because unfortunately as you
know agents and managers will always try
to block stuff if they not get paid so I
think we have to go through PR and find
what are the things that they're
currently promoting yeah well let's
really look at for that vote that 22
what is the thing that's most important
to them now some of them will either
have a new movie or a new television
show or a new book coming out obviously
we've got to make sure that relates to
your audience so we're going to make
sure that they understand that but do
you have a lot of folks so I think that
has a lot of value too
um we just have to figure out which one
of those folks have what - you know what
that's easy to find - it a lot of them
with Kevin Swift on your list Taylor
Swift is on the list yeah I think she
has a new album out somebody just told
me people you know anything like that is
very relevant a new book a new album a
new movie a new television show I think
that will be super helpful and I would
let's go through PR let's not go through
managers and agents and let's go
directly so again I have some pretty
good relationships and how they would
world would see who we who we know and
who you know and you know I think it's
just about banging on the doors I said
we've had Tony Robbins on the channel
once I did a not a face-to-face
interview but remote so he's done 2:23
sorry the 22 and I want to do like for
all these I wanna do face to face not
just like a Skype interview but we're
gonna go see them wherever they are in
the bail of right but then it feels
bigger to them sure yeah so so we can
use that as a as a case study that one
did 1.1 million views so really I mean
it's like one of his top three
interviews anywhere online it's amazing
so we can get on before usually we all
need to create a one sheet can we create
one sheet about this agenda yeah about
what you're trying to promote it has to
be more the mission for them obviously
Heather you getting to ten million
subscribers right now me about crossing
over their message to the business world
of how they were successful right yeah
look lessons small business folks can
take over I think that's the mission of
why we're going after these people yeah
we have to show them the reach of the
show which is the combination of your
YouTube subscribers and your social
media and what I think right away the
first thing the list is your most recent
Tony Robinson if you did over 1.3
million views I mean whose market a lot
that type of you know audience yeah for
some of those folks those numbers are
used right so you know Elon Musk is he's
on the list here right or nice he's on
the list I don't know how it's like guys
like musk he's just done basically Joe
Rogan and not much else besides like
CNBC in that kind of stuff here's what I
think we need to do is we have to have
your folks cut a little trailer for the
show - gotta give them something
that shows them what your stuff is I
love your intro even just your little
intro it's good maybe become a quick
intro with a clip to Tony Robbins
interview a customized hey Tony I'd love
to have you on my channel actually
that's smarter than what I would say it
wasn't even necessarily saying that but
I do like that idea
okay a lot you can come to 22 of those
that's fine that's why did I not say
that work but I love your you know your
espresso intros always cute it always
works for me
it showed you the unique and different
okay
you like me a lot of these guys who like
the fact that you're not you know you
feel young and interesting that if not
like some douche so okay thank you
that's attractive I do so I'm just
saying should we be sending that some
version of that also so let's talk about
so the materials are a one-sheet yeah
custom bomb and a quick clip and I
wasn't saying you should say hey to them
that's great if you do but I think
minimal minimally I would love to see
just the Tony Robbins place with your
intro just a quick little clip from the
Tony Robbins thing that got 1.3 million
so they're just get a look in the field
yeah I'm happy to do angel for each
that's easy I mean it's just a lot of
different let's create one
I would literally make it 30 seconds to
a minute tops that that had to clip from
something else you've done that has your
intro just says hey I'd love to have you
on my show okay
and then let's take it from there I
think that's gonna be super helpful some
of them so like Gary we put on the list
we already have a relationship with him
it's just a matter of figuring out
schedule and timing because I mean for
all these people just a matter of
figuring of schedule and timing - yeah
yeah I think we just have to again let's
go through the twenty to one by one I'll
do that over the weekend and I don't you
know what City Yahoo who knows who and
how do we get to them okay so I should
be able to help get to Gary Vee as well
okay he's the one that we've connected
with the most from anybody on this list
I have no connection to you at all so
there's nobody who's a youtuber besides
Gary on the list yeah I guess we're
gonna bet now like Bill Gates and Warren
Buffett in in Dalai Lama and Michael
Jordan and though I'm still
he's alive he's alive he know he's alive
yeah well I hope so cuz he's got some
but something like that like having the
Dalai Lama talk about entrepreneurship
is different
it's a moment yeah right I think it's
relevant in terms of leadership right
sure
and like having Kanye come on and talk
about entrepreneurship it's never
happened before so it's like not just
about my channel it's about the making a
stamp for the community that this has
never happened we're gonna make we're
gonna be the first to make it happen I
love it absolutely make sure that's
reflected in the one sheet okay so you
want a one page on each and you wanna I
would do a general one sheet don't do
one thing feed our age but give me a
general one shape a one sheet of okay
the opportunity yeah and then a video 30
seconds to a minute highlighting the
benefits correct how about I do why like
who do you want to go after first I can
make like hey Arnold or hey whoever I
think would be a good one Arnold yep I
think have a pretty good relationship to
him in LA okay I'll make a Hey Arnold
video I like Arnold I like Kanye Kanye's
on my wall I don't if you can see him on
this like angle on your left my right
he's on yeah there you go yeah yeah look
I think the end of the day this is
reflective of what we're trying to do
which is to really change the game and
really go for the throat to get you as
big as possible that's all I got for
today what do you got what did I leave
out no I think it's good I mean this
this is a monthly series so like action
steps before next month that we want to
get accomplished definitely get the
Washington or obviously we got to fill
up as many of those feet as possible in
your tour number one yeah and number two
is you know let's have at least three
committed three to five committed by the
end of the month at the end of January
three to five people saying yes I'm in
yep
I'm liking that dude I'm liking that
Steve Carles ladies and gentlemen and I
get series rolling and you know people
are excited to be joining the subscriber
list for Evan Carmichael I like getting
whatever you to over to Millie
by the end of January two million by the
end of January alright that's it that's
a big that's a that's a big jump figure
out let's do it okay so for the 22 we
got it like I'll make the one pager I'll
do the the video and I'll send you
something we can we can split up the
list and start attacking it and update
my audience next month how we're doing
on it
for the tour what else do we need to do
I'm just going through this Kitty's
gonna start mentioning some folks here
that could be local sponsors and things
like that okay we're gonna follow up a
chance Wilson okay and I got a bunch of
other folks I'm following up with okay
okay yeah by next month when we film
this a gamble we'll be in the middle of
the tour so we should have a budget yet
so we'll have a lot of targets by there
cool alright action items bigger game
here we go good luck
four people four people want to find out
more about you where they going Steve
your market media done you know open up
your own like Twitter or Instagram or
something no no not yet we got two Hague
Norman and felony Blake who will meet
Hank soon on the series let me King soon
right he's my brother he's a frontman
but but you're bringing the value here
on this episode goodbye
go thanks Steve right now one of the big
takeaways for me from this video was I
needed to get that intro video out for
the 22 crew the video that we will be
using to show them to hopefully convince
them to come on my channel good news is
I'm a man of action
when I get a challenge I take immediate
action on it and so we have already
created that short intro video and I
wanted to share with you guys to
hopefully inspire you to take some
action as well roll the video hi I'm
Evan Carmichael and I am on a mission to
help people believe in themselves more I
would love to have you on my youtube
channel of almost 2 million subscribers
and 250 million views to share your
perspectives and inspire the world
I've had people like Tony Robbins Gary
Vaynerchuk Satguru Bishop TD jakes Brian
Tracy wim HOF on my channel and I'd love
to have you as my guest my interview
with Tony Robbins has over 1.2 million
views and is now one of his top 3
most popular interviews ever done online
Forbes magazine called me one of the
world's top 40 social media talents Inc
magazine called me one of the world's
top 25 social media keynote speakers
that you need to know but it's not about
the accolades and awards it's about
doing good making a real impact and
spreading a message that matters I'd
love to help spread your message to
millions of people my ask is to come
visit you in your city or on the road
for 30 to 60 minute interview I promise
to bring great questions create an
interview you'll be proud to show your
grandkids and share it with my audience
and the world thank you for your
consideration thanks for having me on
ticket wrote believe if you want to know
why I started on this journey and why I
made the decision to blow up and become
a household name to get to 10 million
subscribers check the link out next to
me I think you'll enjoy that video
continue to believe and I'll see you
there